welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new marvel what if
spider-man video there were a lot of
people going crazy about spider-man's
stuff happening during the Marvel what
if trailer so we'll break it down there
are a bunch of Easter eggs in here
because if you read the Marvel what-if
comic book series the sky is the limit
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we'll do an Amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know what Marvel what if episodes
you want them to do for the series we
got a bunch more details about what's
going on with the episodes a while ago
so also explain that during the video
too but this is mostly meant to be about
what if spider-man episodes so starting
with number 5 this past week a bunch of
websites were claiming that they saw an
alternate version of spider-man
appearing in the Marvel what if trailer
for the Disney Plus series what if is
actually gonna be Marvel's first
animated Avengers spin-off as part of
their big Marvel phase 4 schedule they
announced if you've never heard of any
of the Marvel what if comics the basic
premise is they alter key details in the
history of their most major comic book
events or characters lives one of the
very first what-if comic book stories I
ever read was what if spider-man never
stopped being cosmic Spider Man another
more recent example would be what if
Ultron defeated the Avengers during
Avengers age of Ultron or what if the
Hulk became the Herald of Galactus you
get the idea the reason Marvel is doing
it it's an animated series instead of
live-action it's just so we can get way
crazier with the plot and the number of
characters in each episode without
having to worry about the budget or the
availability of the major a-list
Avengers actors because all the Avengers
actors are coming back to do voices for
their characters for the series because
that's kind of the theme at the Marvel
Disney Plus series like you have all the
one division Falcon and Winter Soldier
stuff that's happening and it's the
actors from the movies playing their
characters it'll be the same deal for
the what-if episodes but it's going to
be animated so they'll be doing
voiceover roles it won't be them on
screen the budgetary reason for doing
what if animated instead of live-action
it's just because when you look at the
other Marvel Disney Plus series like
Falcon and Winter Soldier in one
division they're spending about 25
million dollars per episode that is
crazy a normal episode of television
like agents of shield is closer to like
3 or 4 million dollars and even though 1
division Falcon a Winter Soldier the
Loki
all the other Disney Plus live-action
series are gonna be super huge and epic
if they tried to do what if as a
live-action series they'd have to spend
double that per episode and it would be
a nightmare to try and get all those
actors back on screen at the same time
together could you even imagine them
trying to reshoot Avengers infinity war
in Avengers age of Ultron for their
what-if episodes live-action that would
be a nightmare so number four the big
spider-man moment that everyone saw this
past week or thought that they saw and
the what-if trailer is this Hawkeye
scene it's not clear what episode this
is for because there's images of
alternate versions of characters all
over the place in the trailer but a lot
of people saw this and they felt like it
was what if spider-man didn't become
spider-man instead he became Ronin
Hawkeye Kevin Feige did say that there
would be one what-if episode for every
single Marvel movie and that includes
the spider-man movies like spider-man
homecoming spider-man far from home in
the upcoming spider-man 3 movie funny
side detail too technically they don't
need Sony's permission to make those
spider-man episodes because of a cool
loophole that I'll explain in the
spider-man rights but even though this
character isn't the perfect likeness of
any of the Avengers actors in real life
it still kind of looks a little more
like Jeremy Renner's Hawkeye than Tom
Hollands Peter Parker it's a little
harder to zoom and enhance on this just
because the resolution isn't super great
but Marvel's trying to take big epic
swings with these what-if episodes
that's the whole point in making them
animated in what if spider-man became
Hawkeye just does not sound like a
banger of an episode like you could do
literally anything you wanted to with
this animated spider-man what-if episode
and you decided to turn them into
Hawkeye that just doesn't sound super
exciting so 3 even though they've
released a bunch of other details
recently about the what-if episodes they
haven't officially announced what the
theme of the spider-man what-if episodes
are going to be they've only announced a
couple of the episodes so far in season
1 of this series is only gonna have 10
episodes and we have 23 Marvel movies so
far including spider-man far from home
the other important thing too is they're
not gonna be doing the episodes in the
order of the Marvel movies were
originally released like Iron Man 1 was
the first MCU movie but the first
what-if episode is going to be for
Captain America the First Avenger and
they're doing a black panther episode
during season 1 even though his movie
didn't take place to the tail end of the
Infinity Saga the reason why there
it that way is mostly to mix things up
and for production reasons because a lot
of the actors aren't available when they
need them and then you have people like
Robert Downey jr. who will come back for
the Ironman what-if episodes but he's
not gonna come back immediately right
after they gave him his big send-off an
Avengers end game like they want that to
set for a while people just to live with
the idea that Iron Man in the MCU died
so don't be surprised if we don't see
any Iron Man what if episodes until
season two of that series number two the
spider-man episodes are also a little
bit different because of the Sony Marvel
sharing deal with Tom Hollands MCU
spider-man it gets a little more
complicated for his character
technically Marvel can make as many
spider-man what-if episodes it wants
without Sony's permission which is great
but that's because it's an animated
series and Marvel has the TV rights to
half-hour animation for spider-man Sony
only has the rights to the live-action
and animated movies and rights to
hour-long
live-action television that's why Sony
made spider-man into the spider-verse
but they also announced that they're
making a bunch of live-action spider-man
hour-long TV series we don't know what
all those are going to be but I've done
a couple videos about that so the big
problem with the Marvel what if
spider-man episodes are the Tom Hollands
playing the character it doesn't matter
that it's animation so Marvel's
spider-man what if episodes will mostly
just change things about spider-man's
history in the MCU without involving a
ton of other non spider-man characters
like they're not gonna do what if
spider-man met the Fantastic Four right
out of the gate or what if spider-man
joined the x-men even though that would
be a pretty cool episode can i transport
to this planet the Fantastic Four
it is and there's another who was a big
help to me against carnage and venom my
friend I
even though Marvel and Sony are actually
getting along really well and they're
gonna continue to refine that spider-man
sharing deal so spider-man stays in the
MCU for a long long time you can kind of
tell the Disney doesn't want Marvel
using too many of their other assets
that don't relate to spider-man inside
the spider-man movies like they don't
want to give Sony too much access to the
rest of the MCU so number one a really
good example of the what if spider-man
homecoming episode would be something
more like what if spider-man never met
Iron Man what if Uncle Ben had lived and
on may had been the one to die in what
if spider-man had become full-on iron
man wearing a regular Iron Man suit
instead of the iron spider suit they're
actually kind of doing a version of that
with a Captain America First Avenger
what if episode like what if Steve
Rogers instead of becoming Captain
America getting the Super Soldier Serum
had gotten an Iron Man suit built by
Howard Stark that look kind of like a
World War Two tank the episodes where
you see a lot of the actors crossing
over will mostly be the Avengers what if
episodes for the Avengers movies like
what if the Avengers had not split up
before Avengers infinity war what if
Spiderman had wielded the Infinity
Gauntlet during Avengers endgame some of
the episodes will be way crazier than
others like the Black Panther episode
that they announced literally is what if
Black Panther had become star-lord and
the footage in the trailer is basically
the events of the guardians of the
galaxy movie except it's T'Challa trying
to steal the Power Stone in a very
Wakanda inspired purple Ravagers uniform
so I assume in that scenario his father
is also secretly ego the Living Planet
who did it with his mother from Wakanda
in the Black Panther movie I also
believe Michael B Jordan is coming back
to play kill monger for one of the
episodes too but I don't know this for
that same Black Panther episode or if
it's for another episode because like
the Black Panther example some of the
episodes will be a bit of a mash-up
between the plots of a couple different
MCU movies like Jeff Goldblum implied
that he was going to be working with
Robert Downey jr. on a would offended
like an alternate version of Thor
Ragnarok with Ironman getting stuck on
Sekar at some point then you have the
really crazy episodes like the what-if
Marvel Zombies episode which I'm
assuming is going to be one of the
Avengers movies episodes but this is
basically the entire trailer
[Applause]
face reality it's more than a linear
path it's a prison
of endless possibility
[Applause]
some heroes will rise others will fall
watcher played in this series by the
amazing Jeffrey Wright is it being the
non earthly being who observes all
things we'll see where we take it we
could take it anywhere they haven't said
much about what's going on with the
actual schedule of episodes it was
originally supposed to come out next
summer but because the virus might be
delayed by a couple weeks so everyone
just let me know in the comments what
are you most hyped up about for the
marvel what-if series and what do you
want them to do with their spider-man
episodes if they can do pretty much
anything that they want everyone click
here to learn about a whole bunch of
Marvel MCU Wolverine deleted scenes and
click here for that Justice League
Snyder cut teaser trailer thank you so
much for watching everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight